Hunter what's your favorite type
of are you on
today
do you like shooting or smoking C
more I'm your favorite type of crack
Dave reubin this is the ruin report it's
January 11th 2024 we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals special
shout out to my neighbor Jeff who while
I was walking Clyde this morning drove
his car by rolled the window down said
hey Dave how you you doing just want you
to know my wife is a bigger fan than I
am but we were on a road trip you're
pretty good that's what he said so thank
you Jeff I appreciate it you can come on
by for eggs or milk anytime as always
postgame show Ruben report. locals.com
and uh yes we are almost at Iowa caucus
day thank the Lord Almighty we are
almost there 4 days away Monday is the
Iowa caucus last night CNN had a debate
between Ronda Santa and Nikki Haley VC
did not qualify Chris Christie dropped
out at about 5:00 p.m. he was not
qualifying for the debate either uh and
Donald Trump on Fox had a
competing Town Hall so it's not like he
doesn't have time to show up to debates
but he just wanted kind of the easy
softball thing over on Fox that's fine
it is what it is at this point uh so
we're going to cover a whole bunch
related to that we've got some clips of
The View I'm warning you in advance but
first I wanted to start with saying
that's uh kind of a really sort of OD
well it's either a good or bad I don't
know you decide for yourself ending to a
story that we covered yesterday you know
over the last week or so we've been
covering this Aaron Rodgers fight with
uh Jimmy Kimmel and that Aaron roders
has found himself because he's outspoken
and he didn't want to get the VX and a
bunch of other stuff he's sort of on the
outside of what you're allowed to talk
about as an athlete uh he was doing I
think weekly appearances on the pat mcae
show on
ESPN and as of yesterday uh he will no
longer be doing them uh here's Pat
explaining it to his audience what we do
know is the guy that stopped by
yesterday because quite a conversation
little bit yeah little bit now very
usual not like that the uh yeah so Aron
Rogers Tuesday season 4 is uh done yeah
complete season there's going to be a
lot of people that are happy with that
myself included to be honest with the
way it ended it got real loud and uh
real loud I'm happy that that that is
not going to be my mentions going
forward which is great news we're a
conversation show people are having
conversations we live in a country that
has freedom of speech but also you're
going to have to deal with the
consequences of your freedom of speech
so what I'm saying is we've given a lot
of people who've been waiting for us to
fail a lot of ammo and things to attack
us for over the last week and we would
love to get back to the point where we
just move on and continue to silence all
the haters over here who can't negotiate
as good as I can all the people over
here can't create a show as good as us
and all the people up here who are just
going to always be here and they're
going to hustle and do their thing which
I respect but we need to do that and
that is our Focus that is our goal and
Aaron roders is a Hall of Famer he's a
four-time MVP he's a massive piece of
the NFL story whenever you go back and
tell it he will be a huge part of it we
are very lucky to get a chance to chat
with him and learn from him some of his
thoughts and opinions though do piss off
a lot of people lot of people and uh I'm
pumped that that is no longer going to
be every single Wednesday of my life uh
which it has been for the last few weeks
on Friday obviously I threw us into the
fire as well forever stand by that
everything else though like just can't
do that and not what we want to be known
for and I'm also pumped that not have to
do these types of talks anymore so with
that being said sports are alive right
now okay uh look you you may not be a
big Sports person and as I was saying
during the fight between Aaron Rogers
and Jimmy Kimmel you may not care about
those fights but I think the way that
Ness has leaked into everything so it's
leaked into sports it's leaked into late
night comedy you get all that I think
that is interesting and ESPN now is
saying and Pat saying I'm just not going
to do it anymore I want to get back to
sports I actually respect that one of
the reasons that I don't watch current
Sports anymore and as I always tell you
guys when I'm doing cardio I'm watching
basketball games from the late 80s early
90s NBA is because everything has become
so political I don't turn on basketball
games to be lectured about race or
gender or the rest of it so to that end
I fully respect what Pat did there it's
sort of upsetting I suppose at some
level that the guy who's telling the
truth Aaron roders seems to be the one
being punished here he's being pushed
out of ESPN but that leads to one other
thing on this I think we've got a
picture of the guy uh yeah this is
Oliver Darcy over at uh CNN and we
played a clip of him yesterday saying
how Aaron Rodgers is spreading
misinformation I like that we got that
perfect little screenshot out there of
the bug eyes uh but basically putting
the pressure on he gave this long-
winded talk putting the pressure on how
uh ESPN which is owned by Disney
shouldn't allow for this misinformation
guy this anti vaxer Aaron Rogers to be
on ESPN anymore and lo and behold today
he is no longer on ESPN anymore that I
am concerned about as for Pat running
his show the way he wants to run it and
focusing more on Sports okay that's just
great and that's his prerogative and he
seems to be doing quite a good job of it
uh but I do think this sort of like
that's cancel culture stuff right a guy
on CNN went on purposely to cancel
someone he doesn't like and then Disney
and ESPN did it so that I don't think is
great but I don't think that bug eyed
guy has much of a career left anyway so
anyway let's move on let's get into the
presidential politics stuff uh because
there there's a whole bunch with the the
debate last night Trump's Town Hall some
nonsense on The View and then of course
there's an invasion at the southern
border and there are illegal immigrants
taking over this country mostly in blue
cities you might want to watch out uh
let's start with a clip yesterday from
The View which will set us up nicely for
which direction this country is going in
they had Liz Cheney on and there is
nothing that the corporate press loves
more than a pet Republican a republican
who has no support a republican who
never gets anything done but will always
throw Republicans and conservatives
under the bus and do it while being fed
a small cookie
by the mainstream media so here is
failed Congressional Republican
Republican quote unquote Republican uh
Liz Cheney on The View and Whoopi
begging her to run for
president do you see yourself and I and
would you ever consider being the
conduit to that third party because I
don't know if if the Republican party as
we as we knew it will survive this
because if he ever gets in and we'll
never have any more elections there will
be no more he will stop it and and he's
very clear about that he wants to be
dictator for life okay so I wonder would
you ever consider please would you
please consider being that person
because I got to tell you it I was
really I don't understand how people can
say we're with you we're with you we're
with you and then when you need them
they go oh but we're with him now I
don't understand that and I don't
understand
how you find the grace not to be pissed
at folks you're not you
know well you're you're mad at them but
you're not pissed in them because if you
were pissed in them you would have given
up on them and you haven't and so would
you look Le I think that I'm begging
you look I'm on one
knee there there's so much there and
just the disingenuous nature of what
whoop is doing Whoopi are you you're
begging her so what what are you saying
if she a republican let's you know kind
of washed up Republican runs as third
party you're not going to vote for Joe
Biden and a Democrat you're not going to
be a Democrat anymore because you
believe in whatever Liz Cheney's quote
unquote Republican beliefs are of course
not of course not right like you're
propping up someone that you know is
completely useless you're propping up
someone so that if Trump is the nominee
which I suppose is most likely at this
moment that you hope that Liz Cheney
will run to knock off one or two
percentage points so that Joe Biden can
win so it's like whoopy just kind of
admit the game like we're not that
stupid although I suppose people that
are watching The View are that stupid
you are not that stupid uh by the way
Liz Cheney her Wyoming Congressional run
uh she lost by 37 points to Harriet
Hagman it might be there's some question
about it but it might be the biggest
Congressional loss for an incumbent ever
ever 37 points Wyoming and nobody likes
her she has no support nobody likes her
but you guys get the game the other part
of the game of course is that you must
keep everyone in a constant state of
fear you've got to keep everyone looking
Every Which Way and people are coming to
get them and all that good stuff so
let's go to Whoopi the day before on The
View what's she really afraid of well
Trump might come back and take out the
journalists and the
gays I'm here to say it's ours to lose
it is this country this is what it's all
about either you want it to work forward
thinking you want everybody to have the
ability to say how they feel what they
want to move forward or you don't or you
want somebody who says I'm going to be
on day one I'm going to be a dictator
who says it to you tells you I'mma put
you people away I'm going to take all
the journalists I'm going take all the
gay folks I'm going to move you all
around and disappear you if that's the
country you want you know who to vote
for if that's not if that's not the
country you want you have to make a
decision that's what want still in
aary may they may like that but the I
believe the people of the United States
will make themselves very clear because
people keep telling them what they're
doing media keeps saying this is what
you're doing I see you I see that face
you guys your lips to we'll be right
thank God nobody at that table's a
journalist or they might have something
to worry about uh as for the gays he's
going to take the gay folks first he has
not said that I'm going to come in in
day one I'm going to take the
journalists and the gays also you can't
do that you just because you're in the
office of the presidency you can't just
suddenly do whatever you want we still
do have some vestage of a functioning
government and separation of powers and
all of those things you can't just Round
Up journalists and all that stuff right
is some of his rhetoric over the to of
course it is the thing with G is you you
guys have heard me tell this story
before I was at maral Lago having dinner
with Junior and he and while Trump was
President this was in the middle of the
first impeachment this is December of
whenever that first impeachment was 20
what was that that was 20 I guess and
we're having dinner and Trump is two
tables behind me it's a small room about
20 people with David and and Kimberly
guilfoil uh junior's wife and Junior
says to me at the end of the mill hey do
you want to meet my dad we go up to
Trump Trump's sitting there and I'm kind
of standing above him because he's
sitting and he looks up and and Junior
say says uh Hey Dad I want you to meet
Dave ruin and he looks at me and he's
like he's like I recognize you I
recognize you and I was like oh well I'm
on Fox a lot I'm on Tucker sometimes and
then he looks at David and he goes well
who are you and David goes well I'm his
husband and Trump goes that's great that
is great can I Stand Up and Shake Your
Hands he stands up he shakes our hands
and then he goes he goes you know what
you know what your only problem is you
guys are too handsome you could have any
Chick you want and you want him and then
he's laughing we're all laughing he he
introduces us to Melania can you believe
these two guys are gay he's not rounding
up the gays you brain lit anyway one
more from The View and then we'll move
on uh Sarah Haynes I want to this this
is a shout out for my mom I gave my
neighbor Jeff a shout out today Mom I
want to give you a shout out you always
say that when I'm talking about the view
that Sarah Haynes is saying and I always
call her the blonde that nobody knows
but today I'm using her name and she is
the sanest at that table and I want
Sarah hes to have credit Mom love you
all right right here is Sarah Haynes
pressing Liz Cheney to run for president
because she's a good
person okay whatever but here I'm being
nice to Sarah Haynes I'm sure she's fine
and great and okay this is for you
Mom one thing that um as an independent
bothers me is Independents decide
elections and the way our system is set
up with our primaries and many of them
being closed the the people like me
don't get to participate in choosing
which I think is driving to majorly
partisan elected people like the
margorie Taylor greens like the Donald
Trumps I'm now conceding because I can't
participate in a lot of states that I
would just take a good person someone
who believes in what you've spoken to
and what you've spoken would you ever
run for
president oh well
um I I haven't I'm not going to rule it
out I haven't made a decision um about
that
but but I I think it's really important
when what you said this election cycle
everybody has to go vote everybody has
to go vote and and you've got to be
willing to say look I'm not necessarily
going to vote for the candidate who
belongs to you know the party that I
belong to I'm going to find the
candidate who I know I can trust to
defend the Constitution uh put aside
everything you just saw there for a
second Brock just made a great Point did
I just out my mom as a view Watcher I
think I did that's number one number two
the views on at the same time as this
show that really makes you
wonder anyway what Sarah Haynes said
there wasn't so bright or great or smart
or anything else I'm just giving her
credit by saying her name for a change
um but again asking her to run for
president it makes no sense because
you're not going to vote for her because
you're all Democrats right so you're
you're playing a very duplicitous game
there and by the way if you wanted a
thirdparty candidate who actually might
be able to win because right now he's
usually polling somewhere between 20 and
25% which is extraordinarily high for a
third party candidate and his name is
Kennedy which has a little something to
do with the Democrats and he you
probably have far more in common with
him politically policy-wise than you do
with Liz Cheney you might be interested
in RFK Jr right so I don't know why they
don't have him on the show unless
actually what they're doing is just
trying to peel away votes from the
Republicans and not from the
Democrats anyway there was a debate last
night on CNN uh as I said at 5:00 pm
yesterday uh Chris Christie dropped out
his one supporter was upset about that
uh VC did not uh qualify so he went on a
podcast uh but Dan santis and Nikki did
and they got into it a little bit uh
here's the governor going after Dicky
Haley she doesn't articulate how this
comes to an end except she was asked uh
after the last debate uh by I believe
Megan Kelly and she said you bring it to
an end by bringing Ukraine into NATO but
of course we're a NATO country so if you
bring Ukraine into NATO that puts the
United States at War Megan said that to
her and then she basically gave a word
salad as to how you go from there so
they have sent cash
she supports this 106 billion that
they're trying to get through Congress
where's some of that money going they've
done tens of billions of dollars to pay
salaries for Ukrainian government
bureaucrats they've paid pensions for
Ukrainian retirees with your tax dollars
we've got homeless veterans we have all
these problems this is the UN way of
thinking that we're somehow globalists
and we have unlimited resources to do
you know I think here's the problem you
can take the Ambassador out of the
United Nation but you can't take the
United Nations out of the ambassad all
right I'm only going to show you one or
two more CPS from the debate but that
everything he said there was absolutely
true right you can have your own
feelings on whatever you think we should
be doing or not doing with Ukraine but
Nikki has been Allin on that that we
should endlessly arm them we know we're
giving them boatloads of money we're
paying for all these pensions we have
enough problems here like make the clean
case why we should be there be pointed
out in the previous debate she couldn't
even name three of the provinces in
Ukraine that she wants to give money to
okay fine so that that was just a nice
Moment by DeSantis another nice moment
was they were asked to compliment each
other and I think you'll see a little
bit of a difference in the way they both
went about doing that Governor Dan
santis let me ask you what do you admire
about Governor Haley well look I mean I
think that um you know at the United
Nations um I did think that she she
spoke out strongly on some key issues
and I appreciated that I also appreciate
uh the state of South Carolina my wife
uh is a College of Charleston graduate
uh um her parents lived there for many
many years and so it is a wonderful
State uh there's a lot of great people
there um and I think to be able to have
been Governor there is is a great
achievement and um I uh really
appreciate everyone I've gotten to meet
in South Carolina governor Haley what do
you admire about Governor DeSantis I
think he's been a good
Governor
okay like Nikki come on and I like you
Nikki right like personally I like you
but like come on there's a bunch of
things he LED on covid like Florida's
free low T like there's so much you
could do there he at least had the um
the decency to be like yeah she did a
nice job at the UN which by the way she
did a spectacular job at the UN right
like I think regard even even the most
magga crazy people who now hate her even
though Trump was the one that made her
the US ambassador to the UN they
acknowledged that she did a fine job uh
right there anyway uh it continued a bit
longer and DeSantis was asked about how
he would treat these riots that we're
seeing all over the country a little bit
different differently than Donald Trump
did that that quote from the president
former president Trump is a little bit
Rich because he was president during the
worst rioting in the modern history of
this country the BLM riots in the summer
of 2020 when I saw that happening in
Minneapolis in Florida I called out the
National Guard we had state law
enforcement deployed we said you're not
burning down our cities in this state
and you know what it didn't happen he
sat in the White House and tweeted twed
Law and Order but he did nothing to
ensure Law and Order okay so you can
again have your feelings about that or
not like it actually is true he
repeatedly was tweeting in capital
letters Law and Order but we know what
happened in that summer now it's not
just for the president to deal with
right Governors have to deal with it
Mayors have to deal with what's going on
in their City could you have done more
with the National Guard and everything
else everyone has to just make their own
decision on all that but in any event
they had their debate last night most
people think that the santis won it but
it it made be a moot point if Trump is
uh you know 40 50 points ahead or
whatever it is uh Trump at the same time
was doing a town hall uh on Fox uh and
here he was asked about covid and fouchy
and a bit more take a look and of course
R to santis would would definitely argue
with your uh characterization of how he
handled it but if you go back and look
at the records you will see that the
biggest fan of Dr fouchy was Ronda sanct
demonius he was a big fan he said I go
by
exactly quote I go by what Dr fouchy
said he said that two months in all the
way through and then eventually changed
when it wasn't you know that wasn't the
desert of the day but Ronda sanas was a
big Dr fouchy fan and nobody wants to
cover that I say it every time okay the
fact first off that the name calling
thing D sanctimonious D Sancus the fact
that the hosts aren't like how about you
just don't do that like you're trying to
be president again but I get it we're
past that nobody cares he's allowed to
do whatever he wants whatever it took us
two seconds to make this edit two
seconds well how long did it take you it
took you more than two seconds you're
working hard over there it took Brock 15
or 20 minutes to put together this edit
as Donald Trump is telling people that
he didn't lock anybody down and that the
sank this wanted the lockdowns blah blah
blah now look 15 minutes it took us to
put this thing together would you ever
allow a shutdown in the future you're
talking about a covid shutdown correct
no I wouldn't and I never did we did the
right thing we CL Clos the country down
I could have kept it open and I could
have done what some countries are doing
I had to shut it down we did the right
thing Florida did shut down run to sanct
is shut down we're in a place called
Florida and we have a great Governor
great governor knows exactly what he's
doing terrific job he just announced
that the schools will be open Governor's
done a great job Florida is down low now
and the China virus he shut a state down
very violently and you're open and you
didn't close and you're just amazing
right it's great one of the greatest
governors in our country and I know a
lot of good ones and I can tell you
there's some really bad ones too but
this is a great one Governor Ron desan
is again make your own decision on that
like the the thing is that Florida did
close for a little bit like every state
did close for a little bit to one degree
or another the difference is that Ronda
santis very quickly realized that was a
mistake very quickly realized that
mandates and force vaccines and all this
stuff was a mistake and then Florida
became as he called it the Citadel of
freedom for the entire world it is
literally the freest place in the entire
world and Donald Trump is doing what
Donald Trump does which is a series of
confusions and lies and he knows that
his Bas loves the lies and they don't
mind being lied to about things that
apparently they feel very passionately
about right because the Bas hates the
vaccines hates operation warp speed
hates the mandates all of those things
and Trump seems to show no regret the
santis is like yeah I screwed up at the
beginning and then I turned around I
personally think that's what a leader
does all of that being said I want to
give Trump some credit now because uh he
does deserve credit for certain things
and I did vote for him last time and I
might vote for him next time because
politics really blows um here is
Trump last night on his town hall saying
that he has no time for Retribution if
anything his retribution will be doing
the right thing for the country well
first of all a lot of people would say
that that's not so bad look what they
did Russia Russia Russia hoax the FBI
Twitter hoax the 51 intelligence agents
hoax all of these different hoaxes that
they did I mean you know a lot of people
would say that's probably quite normal
I'm not going to have time for
Retribution we're going to make this
country so successful again I'm not
going to have time for Retribution and
and remember this our ultimate
retribution is Success our that's a good
line that's a good line and that
actually is the truth right the
retribution is not arresting the
journalists and the gays as Whoopi is
trying to scare to think the retribution
is oh you guys tried to impeach me you
tried to remove me from the ballots you
Unleashed Co on the world to get rid of
me like all that stuff I'm just going to
fix stuff right we're going to fix the
Middle East we're going to get our
economy going again we're going to do
things that will Empower people to live
better lives that would be good that's
the message I think Trump should have
should have been running on this entire
time instead of the Endless Lies about
to santis but again it may all work I
suppose we'll find out in about four or
five days um here is Trump uh talking
about what he's going to do related to
this disastrous uh problem that we're
having on the southern border we have
millions and millions of people here it
is not sustainable did you see in New
York City where they're getting the
regular students out and they're putting
migrants in their place we are going to
have the largest deportation effort in
the history of our country we're
bringing everybody back to where they
came from we have no choice uh can you
do something about the sanctuary cities
yeah well they're going to be ended
because the Democrats are going to end
them because you can't sustain it if you
look at New York you have a mayor of New
York who Now is really hostile to the
administration because New York City
that's my place I love New York it's
gone it's had a tough time okay we're
going to have the largest deportation in
American history his line exactly his
line was we're going to get everyone out
now we know that even before this last 6
months of bananas just endless
immigration into the country illegal
immigration into the country we know
that there are about 12 million illegals
in the country so you have to decide do
you think that he will actually do it
and do you think that that's the right
policy to remove people and some of the
children who've been here and and all of
the issues around that it's very easy to
say I'm going to get rid of everybody
now he didn't last time right he offered
amnesty to an awful lot of people now I
get it things have changed enough people
have woken up to what's going on at the
border maybe he'd have more juice to do
it this time but you just have to decide
again to the backdrop of what we just
showed you like his obvious lies on Co
like do you think he actually would get
rid of those people do you think he
would build a wall this time blah blah
blah but at least the messaging there is
truer and certainly better than what the
Democrats are getting giving us right
now because the Democrats have given us
a completely open border and as we
covered yesterday this story is so
profoundly insane that I don't think
anyone in their right mind would have
believed this even three years ago a
school in Brooklyn James Madison High
School in Brooklyn closed 2,000 students
were not allowed to go to school and had
to work remote so that they could allow
illegals to take over the school and uh
get food and Healthcare and all of this
other stuff a mom at James Madison High
School uh recorded this video this is
from two days
ago oh this is cut this is bed they're
bringing in
food
why
not why
not I got to see where my tax dollars
are
going good woman look they are kicking
legal taxpayers their children out of
school to house these illegals and this
is what New York City has brought onto
itself right they were Sanctuary State
Sanctuary City congratulations and now
well I think you're basically uh turning
a lot of probably marginal Democrats or
moderates into Republicans it may not
matter at the end of the day in New York
that's just the demographics of New York
but people are pissed and they rightly
are pissed and it's and it's it's
something that we I suppose you know
three years ago we wouldn't have
believed it but we kind of all should
have seen it coming uh you might
remember this one this is six months ago
in Massachusetts when the government of
Massachusetts look at this they are
literally telling people to give up
rooms in their houses to illegals most
importantly if you have an extra room or
Suite in your home please consider
hosting a family safe housing and
shelter is our most pressing need become
a sponsor family you can contact the
Brazilian Worker Center for more
information on how you can step up if
you're willing to have an additional
family be part of your family if you're
a local official a college President a
business owner or a faith leader with an
available building or space in your
community please work with us to offer
it as a shelter site if you're a social
service provider please consider
becoming an emergency assistance
homeless shelter provider our resources
are stretched thin there as well and if
you're a hotel or a motel owner consider
opening it up for emergency assistance
if you're a landlord or a property owner
we can use you to can connect you with
service providers to help transition
families into permanent housing everyone
has something they can offer what an
endless bunch of BS ironically you
people don't have anything you can offer
your your government Stooges who uh have
wrecked the border and then you want
people to give the empty rooms in their
houses to a bunch of people that we have
no idea what they believe you want
landlords to not make money but just to
let people take over you want churches
to give up like this is what an
absolutely
dysfunctional really communist
craptastic government would offer and
it's happening in all of uh the blue
States and blue cities I just want to do
a little bit more and then we'll get to
the Ruben report community Community Q&A
you might remember a couple months ago
we showed you some video from El Paso
Texas which of course is a Border Town
and their airport there which had
basically been completely taken over
with illegals now that didn't make it to
CNN or to MSNBC or on to the New York
Times because nobody cares about that
because El Paso it's Texas it's thought
of as Republican so nobody really cares
there you move these people up to
Martha's Vineyard then we got World War
III on our hands right well now it is
spreading because we are letting these
people in and we are sending them across
the country check out this video from
Chicago oare airport yesterday which has
sectioned off a portion of the air
airport to now house illegal
immigrants enough
picture it's an airport it's an
airport
[Music]
FL Chicago oare airport congratul
congratulations Sanctuary City Chicago
does that seem good to you does that
seem just to you does that seem like
something that you want your tax dollars
to pay for do we have any idea where
those people are coming from I thought
there was some big pandemic I keep
seeing these Hamas supporters uh in the
streets protesting with masks on are
these people coming in with masks do we
give them covid tests anything does
anything work and that is what leads us
to the political part of this which is
we are at this preent moment right now
where we're about to choose and you
better choose carefully otherwise will
get exactly what we deserve all right
we're going to go to the Ruben report
Community Q&A in just a second let me
talk to you guys about truly office
first guys this might sound unbelievable
but the quickest way to secure your
personal data is to ditch mainstream
mainstream office software providers
like Microsoft and Google who misuse
your data without your permission and
switch to a safer alternative like truly
office software once you switch you'll
never look back because truly office
software gives you peace of mind and
control over your personal data truly
office software is secure private and an
alternative to mainstream office
software it doesn't track or sell your
data giving you complete control over
your personal information and getting
started is a breeze right now they're
offering a free trial of truly office
software just for our viewers and
listeners so you can try it out before
you buy just go to truly
office.com Rumble to start your journey
towards data privacy and security before
you commit to another office software
that invades your privacy consider truly
office software it's the secure private
alternative you've been looking for
go now to truly office.com Rumble and
try it for free this offer is limited so
don't miss out and now back to me all
right Ruben report. locals.com Community
Q&A if you want to join us right now
we'll see if we can uh get an extra
question or two in on the Fly Lynn says
hey Dave have you watched the film
Maestro yet on Netflix if so what did
you think I watched it and had mixed
feelings I have not seen it yet I know
it's about lonard Bernstein uh I would
like to watch it at some point uh but
ironically uh last night I was watching
Seinfeld as I do almost every night and
the Maestro episode of Seinfeld was on
when Jerry ends up having to uh rent
that house in Tuscany and all of that
and I will watch it that wasn't a great
answer for your question since I didn't
see it but here we are uh and I'll I'll
report back to on what I think uh Mary
says what do you think the next Crisis
will be and do you think there's a way
to turn it around that's always the
thing because you know people talk about
remember we played you that clip what
was it about uh it was probably right
before the Christmas break about oh no
was it after Christmas it happened
during Christmas break I think it was
our first show back that that person
went on ABC or CBS News and said that
there's going to be a Black Swan event
that was that was after Christmas right
yeah um and a Black Swan event the idea
that just out of nowhere something's
going to happen that changes the game
alog together meaning 911 was a Black
Swan event covid and subsequent
lockdowns Black Swan event like what's
the next thing I mean conventional
wisdom is that it's going to be some
sort of Internet blackout that's what
everyone keeps saying to me the more
keep saying it the less I think it is
going to be that is there going to be
like an EMP that goes off in a major
city and All Electronics will go down
will they have they'll be like oh co is
back but actually yes that last one that
was kind of a hoaxy thing but this one's
20 times worse than covid is there going
to be some flesh eating virus is there
going to be a nuke that goes off who the
hell knows I don't know what you can do
other than make sure you've got some
extra food in your house if you can get
a generator get a generator I would say
largely unfortunately living in cities
is no longer a great idea uh for a
series of reasons related to homeless
and drugs and that Services collapse and
you don't have an ability to have a you
know a storage area for your family uh
we're building out a new uh Garden area
right now as we speak and growing some
more stuff like make sure you've got
some guns like you can just do the stuff
that you can do to control your little
world you can't control the big world
but you can have some control over your
little portion of existence X house says
any good stories from high school or
college do anything crazy funny or
interesting did you ever have a
girlfriend or had you already figured
out by then that that wasn't your thing
uh I did have some girlfriends in high
school actually my first my girlfriend
in high school my high school prom night
uh was June I think it was June 17th
maybe the 19th June 17th or 19th uh 1994
it was the night of the OJ Simpson car
chase my prom was at the Waldorf
historia New York City I went to high
school in Long Island but the prom is in
New York City Waldorf his story in New
York City it was the night of the OJ
Simpson car chase and it was also the
night of game six of the 1994 NBA Finals
remember John Stark shooting that three
at the end Elijah Juan's fingers just
nickit and uh gets to game seven uh I
will not tell you about the rest of that
evening because this is a family show um
other things that I did you know college
I I I was like pretty much a kind of
pothead in college I was mostly playing
basketball and smoking pot and playing
video games probably should have paid
attention a little bit more but I guess
it all worked out keto says uh Nevada or
Nevada I should say they corrected me
when I was in Reno Nevada did not put
Trump or DeSantis on our general
election mail in ballot I looked up why
and it says because they opted for a
caucus I've never seen this in all my
years can someone explain to me what is
a caucus and does this mean I don't have
a say in the general so in that we have
an Iowa caucus and Iowa is the most
famous caucus that's coming up on Monday
I thought we'd give you an official
answer on this one so here we go I'm
reading this so follow along caucuses
are meetings run by political parties
that are held at the County District or
Precinct level some caucuses choose
candidates by secret ballot here's the
key part others require participants to
divide themselves into groups according
to the candidate they support undecided
participants form their own group each
candidate's group gives speeches and
tries to get others to join their group
at the end the number of delegates given
to each candidate is based on the number
of caucus votes they received so that is
what's going to happen in Iowa and
apparently that's what uh Nevada is
doing as well it's super interesting
because it's not
just you know check mark hand this in
and that that's my vote like they
literally they have these precincts you
get these caucus uh what do they call
them leaders or coaches or deputies and
they basically you Wrangle in people and
you have a certain amount of people in
that corner that are voting for this guy
and a certain amount of people in this
corner that are voting for this guy and
you're having conversations in
gymnasiums and libraries and schools and
you're trying to get the most people to
come to your side so those undp sided
people they show up and in a case like
Iowa you've got a guy like Ronda sanis
went to all 99 counties everyone pretty
much knows who he is everyone obviously
knows who Trump is at this point christe
just dropped out like there's all of
these moving pieces you might go well
this guy has momentum this one doesn't
have momentum but that's why there's
something super interesting about the
caucuses and uh we shall see what
happens en cadus says hey Dave if you
could go back in time what event or
person would you like to see oh if you
could go back in
time what event or oh there's a lot
there there's a lot
there
um well I think I you I mean that's
going to sound a little cliche for me
but like to to have been around with the
Founding Fathers as they were crafting
the founding documents like as they were
crafting Federalist Papers the
Declaration of Independence eventually
the Constitution the Bill of Rights like
the debates that they were having like
our political debates these days are
just so stupid like even when we show
you know our debates literally I just
showed you some clips of our debates
like they're so not substantive it's
just about the show and the personality
and does he have it and how many lives
did that person have in the rest of it
where we used to have really serious
people you know 250 years ago we had
serious thinkers that were grappling
with all sorts of the issues I mean the
one that I always go back to is that our
Founders many of whom were slave owners
uh were also writing the laws to free
the slaves they they lived with that
complexity they were people of their
time and they were trying to figure
things out that George Washington led
the Revolutionary War and was president
and the second the Revolutionary War was
over he put that he said I will not lead
the Army anymore he could have right he
could have remained the president and
led the Army but he knew that that would
be bad for the nation when he died his
his half of the slaves that he owned
were freed but Martha his wife her
slaves were not like that's that's
complex Thomas Jefferson was literally
having relations with slaves uh that
that he you know owned in essence quote
unquote owned while writing the
documents that were freeing the slaves
over time like to just have been around
people that were serious thinkers trying
to do things that that got the documents
right too I guess that's it more than
anything else that if you just for all
the problems that we have in this
country country we need only look at the
documents that they handed Us in the
first place if we could just go back to
can we do things by the Constitution do
we know what the Bill of Rights actually
means what is federalism and why does
States why do why should most things be
done by States if we could just go back
to those basic things that those
brilliant complex people figured out
that would be pretty sweet so I would
have loved to have been a part of that
crafty Barb says walking with the hubby
today uh about uh walking with the hubby
today about Michelle Obama to be the
possible democ ratic nominee for
president he said she would win over
Trump your thoughts you know a lot of
people seem to be saying right now that
if they figure out the way to get rid of
Biden that it's not going to be Kamala
because nobody likes her so they have to
figure out the trick there I said it you
know for several months I think they
were really pushing Gavin and I think
that Dan santis did a freaking hell of a
job at that debate and that just blew up
in desantis's uh in in nome's face we've
pretty much not heard from Nome since
then right like that was the test Tri
can this guy do it he came off as as
unlikable and dishonest the policies are
bad like even if the santis doesn't win
this thing on Monday and never becomes
president he did a great service to this
country not only because of what he's
done in Florida but he basically took
out Nome so that's good but that does
mean they need need someone else and a
lot of people are saying it's Michelle
Obama I don't know I mean Michelle you
know Barack Obama seems to be running
this thing already but yes Biden could
just fall down the stairs or fall up the
stairs or break down mentally any day
now and everything else I would say I
would say she'd be in the top five of
who they would select out of this thing
Rich says hey Dave I've seen a number of
articulate conservative commentators
being interviewed about the coming
Financial apocalypse and the general
collapse of the West oh great is it
happening this weekend is it or I
hopefully not we're all going out for
dinner tonight I hope it's not tonight
when asked if America can turn it around
and survive and survive the coming
apocalypse oh wait uh oh wait sorry go
back for a second when if America can
turn it around and survive the coming
collapse the articulate conservative
commentators become Tongue Tied do you
think America can turn it around and
survive da well that's why I think this
election is just so freaking important
you know my thoughts on this that not
everything can be solved by our
politicians but I don't think everything
could be solved by Liars I think we need
we need s new juice we need people that
are younger like we can do this and and
I think there's so many of us that want
to be good citizens in this country and
that want to be led by good people and
all of those things but that silent
majority that silent majority it's like
unless you're willing to be a throw some
skin in the game get involved and get
good people out there one of my fears
that is that if the disantis thing
doesn't work and it's just so profoundly
obvious to me that he's he's the this is
a generational candidate and and it just
may not work it may not I do conc that
obviously right but like if it doesn't
work I don't know who who's be the next
good guy to come after this now I would
say RFK Jr is a good guy too I have some
different political disagreements with
him but like good people are just going
to be like there is just no more point
in this between all of the that
they will do to me and my family it's
clearly being shown to us that if you're
just a good guy with a good track record
and you do the right things and you have
no drama and you have a good family that
that's not the there's no path for you
to win so we could just extend all of
this craziness and I think that that's a
problem I I as for the coming Financial
IAL apocalypse I've talked to my money
guys they do sense a lot of weirdness in
the market right now obviously the
Middle East is very unstable our borders
like there's just so much like we just
the whole thing feels like it's in in
flux I would say the best thing you can
do is diversify your portfolio if you
have one you guys know my feelings about
real estate like a building is a
building owning something that is
physical I think is important maybe a
little bit of gold a little bit of
crypto like making sure just it's just
not all just sitting in that bank and
then one day you go to the at and
they're like n n nah no more uh Lloyd
says you've been cancelled for violating
some Community sensibilities you are
sentenced to a year isolated on a
deserted island you will be provided one
meal the same meal for all 365 days what
is that
meal one meal all day 300 you know
what my my initial reaction was chicken
parm but like chicken parm three times a
day like 365 days that's going to take
you out I think I could I could do just
a really good ribeye just give be a good
ribey and we know that through Jordan
and others that the carnivore diet or as
they now call it I suppose the lion diet
like for some people it really does work
I think I would be one of those people I
feel great we eat a lot of red meat I
feel great when I'm eating red meat and
if I'm eating red meat and just veggies
oh if it you didn't say one food one
meal so give me give me a really nice
bone in ribeye um give me some sauteed
spinach and I don't even need the carbs
but I'll take some like some simple uh
baked potato or something like that I
think I would I would be good to go you
guys want to toss anything in what do
you you want like you want like gummy
bears or something you have Brock just
loves the gummy bears you could have
said chicken parm on the side with
chicken parm on the side of the steak
that's that's not the what the rules are
happy says do you and David get date
night anymore or do you just fall
exhausted into bed at night after taking
care of your career in those two crumb
snatchers man uh well everyone right now
you know one of the things that you find
out as a parent very quickly uh no
matter how you know clean you keep your
house and feeding them well and
everything else is that kids are sick a
lot like we have you know I have cousins
that come over and family coming over
and everyone's on planes and coming and
come so the boys are a little under the
weather at the moment today actually
Luke over the weekend uh we had our
first stitches here Luke was on the
basketball court and he tripped he
whacked his chin just like kind of right
under in here uh on an outdoor light and
he got three Little Stitches he's going
to be okay he's going to be just fine so
but he's got a bandage over here um but
it's exhausting like it is really really
exhausting so the answer to your
question is um I cannot remember the
last time the two of us went out just
the two of us I actually it's it's been
quite some time U you know we had
friends over for for New Year's and that
sort of thing I'm I'm going out with the
team tonight but yeah there's a lot of
nights these days where like 9:00
David's like done and at in bed and you
know I'll watch Seinfeld or fiddle
around or whatever for a bit um but but
you know it's a it's a phase in life as
everyone says like the first year first
two years it's a phase in life and then
we will get to that but I've got it good
I'm not complaining Flor Manchu says
since generally Republicans and
Democrats are seen as two wings of the
same bird do you think Republican
control over the presidency House and
Senate will actually lead to positive
change or do you think they will just
continue to make empty promises and
grand stand for the next four years well
I think things would be better to a
degree right I mean what do I always say
like I consider myself a Florida
Republican cuz I can Define that very
easily and I can look at the results of
what having a super majority of
Republicans in the house here and a
governor and and mayors that are largely
Republican like a true Republican Run
state that is good and safe and decent
and all that stuff the national
Republicans usually suck they suck a
little bit less than the Democrats um
but I do think if you had a republican
House a Republican Senate and a
Republican president I think there would
be every reason to believe that the
Border would be in a much better
position I think there would be every
reason to believe that they would hack
away at some of the administrative state
that taxes would be lowered that our
fall foreign policy would be a little
bit cleaner and more sensible like
Republicans are not great but they're a
little bit better and if they had enough
if they had a moral good leader with a
track record of success that they could
follow to the promised land I think they
could get there who might be that person
that's up to you Iowa uh CeCe says it is
important to be able to do different
voices to or is it important to be able
to do different voices to be a comedian
you seem to do several and it's always
very funny I don't think I've busted out
the Indian accent lately but here it is
um I don't know I I always was kind of
doing those things I don't really think
about what I'm doing on the show when
I'm doing the gay accent or whatever
else I'm doing like it just kind of just
comes and uh you know everybody does
things uh a little bit differently what
else do I do Bernie Sanders I'm B wait
wait what's my Bernie Sanders uh Bernie
S no that's not Bernie Sanders I can't
do it on the
Fly what oh Bernie
Sanders get so kind of a word for that
one how about Jackie Mason a schmuck
like me I'm Jackie Mason I'm here I'm
having dinner I'm Cooper says which game
console did you end up picking
personally I think you should get a
switch uh I'll verse you in Smash BRS
all right so we've got a PlayStation 5
there we're going to start streaming
some stuff so I can get away from Pure
politics all the time we're continuing
this show obviously it'll be a separate
thing alog together but we've got a PS5
right there it's oh the Box is open it's
connected oh yeah it's here can't can I
touch a remote maybe give me a remote
give me something show the people that
it's actually in the room and ready to
roll we've got a remote there all right
so A PS5 is in here uh we also have the
8bit Nintendo Entertainment System ready
oh yeah there's a picture we were
testing Mario Brothers 2 last night so
the 8bit NES is in the house and yes I
do have a switch also I have not played
video games in Forever a fan sent me a
switch when I was on tour with Jordan
and I would played the switch a little
bit when I was on the plane and stuff
and then I I was playing that Zelda game
uh breath what is it breath of the wild
breath of the yeah and it was pretty
good but then something with the
parachute and I couldn't figure out how
to put it on and then then I have my own
problems you know what I mean I I had to
stop playing but yeah we we're going to
figure out a bunch of stuff and we're
going to squat up right that's what the
kids do now when you're playing with
other people you squat up and if you're
all playing really well that means you
have a lot of gas that's what I've been
told no that's not a lot of gas what do
you mean I thought if you're doing
something really well you have gas no
something is like good like if it tastes
good that's gas oh if something tastes
good that's gas yeah sound that can be
gas you're using it as a verb I think
it's more you can describe
something the point point is I'm very
gassy Eliza says can you get Jordan
Peterson to wear jeans and cowboy boots
for 30 days and we'll see if he can
actually chill I would like to see
Jordan in jeans you know I've seen
Jordan in jeans he's usually pretty well
dressed in the three-piece suit these
days uh but when we were torn I would
see him in jeans in the morning um a
cowboy boots uh you know he does do some
stuff with the daily wire so he's over
there in Nashville every now and again
could get some boots and uh you know
he's just uh Jordan is Jordan when you
see Jordan what you get on camera is off
camera Jordan it's it's the exact same
thing Frank says hey Dave did you see
the USA Today article about Ray EPS it
paints him as the victim of a merciless
crowd of Maga Republicans coming after
him because of the false accusations
made by Tucker and others what are your
thoughts on him so I I didn't see that
article specifically but Ray EPS was
basically the one guy he's this very
tall guy he was the really the one guy
that you see in a lot of those January 6
videos who's like go to the capital he's
like leading people into the capital and
then suddenly the media New York Times
New York are all Washington Post they're
all writing these articles how Ray EPS
is being used by the rightwing and he
wasn't a bad guy and it's like I don't
know I'm like is he a Fed probably like
something feels very off because what
what was the punishment he got it was
like six mons he got six months
probation or in jail jail six months
jail little bit of a fine or something
and it's like he was the one that was
like let's go to the capital meanwhile
there are people rotting in jail right
now that did far l so I don't know
exactly what to make of that all right
one more for you Elizabeth says if you
were to plan a perfect day what would be
on the
agenda um well I can tell you what one
thing that would be nice is a little
quiet in the morning right my mornings
are not that quiet anymore I do I have a
lot of fun with the guys in the morning
but like you know just like having a cup
of coffee without having milk squirted
on me or you know having to change a
diaper that that would be nice but uh no
joking is I like a nice quiet cup of
coffee in the morning maybe be sitting
by the beach uh would be really nice um
if I could do a little exercise play a
little basketball in the afternoon uh a
nice cocktail maybe uh you know just
some beautiful uh tequila would always
be great at night a great meal I like
I'm very very simple I I like good music
I like good food I I like quiet um I
don't need much more than that and I I
love a I love a good hammock got to get
a hammock guys my birthday next June
right down hammock I don't know why I
don't have a hammock I got a lot of
trees here yeah just like something
simple I don't need much like I don't
need a lot of simulation I don't need a
lot of craziness just quiet food I don't
know I guess a friend or two could swing
by you know that's it people of the
internet live at 100m and uh if you want
to join us for the postgame show coming
up momentarily Ruben report. locals.com
oh and we leave you with a cold clo if
you didn't see it they found uh under
the well just watch the cold clothes I
can't really explain this it's a little
bizarre but enjoy good
[Music]
bye